very
sad no but I'm really okay I just cried
a little bit where do you where are you
uh headed where's home oh okay just on
the other side I'm Sor can I help you
stand no I'm okay I'm being very honest
I'm not really I'm not even drunk I'm
just okay can you stand up please mhm so
it's
22° just a little bit cold it's really
cold it's just like this much
yeah I'm not even drunk I'm being honest
I didn't drink anything I'm just okay
then then what why are you not able to
keep your balance CU I'm very sad okay
so if it's not alcohol what is it
sadness you know okay so please don't
lie to me you always have the right to
remain silent you do not have the right
to lie yeah my primary concern is your
safety yeah so I realize you're not
feeling the cold because of your
emotions and alcohol and whatever else
is going on yeah but I don't want you to
freeze to death out here I won't I'm
like I live right down the street okay
can you show me which way goldsworthy is
from here that way and then you go down
the street and then ride down the street
from here you know it's a little farther
than right down the street but yes
that's a direction it's like pretty
right down the street from here okay I
don't have my IDE on here but I am
21 okay I pinky promise but I don't
what's your date of birth my date of
birth
9:22
20 that Mak and you're how old
23 almost 23 okay so it does me me
almost 23 okay so you don't know how old
you
are it would unusual for someone who's
almost 23 to be living in the D
I don't want to buy my own apartment
because I can't afford it okay but I can
afford to live in the
dorms what's your last name Craig c r a
i and your first name Mary M A R Y and
your middle
initial e e date of
birth
[Music]
two wait hold on let me
think not to
22 0
Z how old are you 20
22 that's are you asking me a question
no I'm thinking for on what's your phone
number
well that's my mom's I can't
remember but I remember 46 named
California last of Craig Charles Robert
Adam Ida George first of Mary Mary Adam
Robert Young middle initial e Edward
dead birth
0922 female
California
wait I'm
thinking
good
copy
so is that your sister's
name fuck I don't even know I
think shit I don't
know my name is Mary Craig what's your
date of birth
9225 shit I'm so mad
I'm sorry I can't
even just know I know 46 what's the date
of birth on the
return I can tell you fuck I'm so sorry
I lied
09 22 what's your room number in
Gold I don't know
man
I just want to go to
Streep copy can you try 09
2205 can I tell you that I'm A
[Music]
Min I am 35's
here and you're from South
Prairie yes how did you know cuz I
looked you up in the WQ system cuz you
were lying to us about your birthday I'm
so sorry I didn't mean
to I think I told you my
sisters
so do you live near her I do
okay the same building good I'm
I'm it's
okay
copy so um I'm so sorry I didn't mean to
lie to you we just keep rning your mouth
yeah so your friend's not really able to
get you where you're
going uh so I'm going to place you under
arrest for your own safety to make sure
you don't freeze out here I'm so sorry
so go ahead and put your hands behind
your back
please
[Music]
so since you are under arrest I am going
to advise you your constitutional rights
you do have the right to remain silent
anything that you do say can and will be
used against you in a court of law you
also have the right to an attorney and
to have an attorney present before and
during any questioning or the making of
any statements if you so desire if you
cannot afford an attorney stand up for
me uh one will be appointed by the court
without cost to you do you understand
your rights MH okay uh you're also being
audio and video recorded there is a
camera on my shoulder
and it's 1:53 a.m. on October 28th
2023 keep standing I'm uh so you are
under arrest for a minor in public place
exhibiting the effects of having
consumed liquor and making false or
missleading statements to a public
servant so I'm going to take you to the
Poland police department and make sure
you're safe and warm and uh a few hours
from now we'll make sure that you get
where you need to
go do you have any questions for me
do you have her like room number and
everything to make sure she gets where
she needs to be uh
yes um and you can talk to Sergeant Boyd
and see if you can have the warmer place
to
go so come with me
please my phone where are you
going okay you want to
ride
so s oh I just want you to be
safe I'm supposed to be a doctor so
that's okay am I supposed to stand there
yep stand right there spread your feet
for me a little bit do you have anything
in your pockets that I should be
concerned about M okay just my phone
okay what's this I don't know oh shit
it's my friend's babe she put it in my
pocket so I can keep it safe okay and an
UNO card oh yeah UNO card
okay and what's here I don't know it's
chapstick ChapStick and I think it
look okay how much do you think this
will
cost keep standing keep
standing okay carefully step in and have
a seat put your left foot in first slide
to the
side think I can go home tonight uh
later tonight yes so why' you have to
throw up if you didn't drink anything I
didn't say I didn't drink anything yes
you did you said you weren't drunk
oh I told you had to drink a little bit
and then I had to I think you're
just um can you head un
me stand up please I'm
standing these hurt very badly okay
we'll get them off once we get inside
here oh no are we in the police station
yep I'm very sorry I didn't mean to do
this is locked yep it'll be unlocked
here in a
second listen
you I didn't even think I that much I
think it's CU I
didn't I didn't me I thought I would eat
dinner tonight but then I
didn't who's that standing in the office
there she's very
pretty can I talk to her can I tell her
that she's very pretty no okay can you
kick your shoes off please they're tied
I can't oh okay they're my fat
shoes can you untie them please and then
I can K them off nope
okay and then I'm holding my th but I
don't B oh my
to I don't B you okay I'm just my
friend you think me hope so did
I'm okay anything in your back
pockets not
okay anything in your bra besides body
parts
I you're welcome to check St you need
to oh I think I have an UNO card in here
I do have an UNO card in here okay it's
a Skip One okay so I can tell men I can
you sit down please so you don't fall
down I would love
to I'm very
sorry well I just want you to be
safe can I tell my mom that I'm
sorry uh can I see your hat please my
hat
yep thank you
welcome uh can I see your jacket for a
moment I'm just wearing it cuz I'm cold
I left it outside the
party where were you drinking um the
hockey house the hockey house
yes
okay so it's kind of cold in here so I'm
going to let you keep this with you
thank you I appreciate
it okay stand up please I would love to
thank you
sir are you going to hold me overnight
basically yes I don't think my mom would
like that very much step in
here
[Applause]
oh
hello
[Applause]
how you
feeling
okay uh can I get your cell phone
number and what's your address here in
pulman
oh
thank
you and where were you born
um
[Music]
Miss Hospital down in
California
okay
uh so we have more paperwork to do uh
but we'll be back to get you in
hopefully within an
hour how you doing I'm officer Ley I'm
going to work on getting you out of here
okay so first thing we going to do is
we're going to take a picture two
pictures just going to have you stand
over here no handcuffs or nothing you
just got to stand by the by the wall
after that we're going to do some
fingerprints that can be a little timec
consuming maybe 10 minutes and then
after that we'll be out of here okay you
have any questions what time is it oh
what time is it it is 8:22 in the
morning yeah
yep all
right hang on just a
[Music]
second this thing there you go all right
Walk This Way With Me go to that corner
there take a right turn
you feeling all right yeah so stand
right here by this blue look at that guy
right
there I know we're almost out of here
and it's cold outside this is a better
place to be hey Sam you
good look right
here
without so without turning your body see
that red dot look right at that and just
stay
still okay great this is a new thing so
that work all right come on over here
stand right here I'm going to ask you do
you have any scars marks or tattoos no
no no tattoos all right so we're going
to move right along
man no I don't want that
Mis lanus identification nope not going
to do
that
okay we going to do
fings all right let's see how this works
sometimes it's finicky but there's no
ink so we're not going to stay any
clothes
okay you got someone coming to pick you
up all right we can make a phone call
and figure out so left hand flat I want
these four fingers on this left hand
right here come on yep step on over and
I'm going to guide you through this just
don't press too hard
right there we
go try
that cool lift up uh right thumb no left
thumb so get your left thumb on
there okay right
thumb let's redo that one let's
that don't push just too
much there we go and right hand
flat
right thumb roll these ones get tricky
so I'm going to start over here and
we're going to roll to the
left oh there you took it right index
there you
go
right
middle you got any friends in town yep
all right maybe one of them can come
pick you
up it's your option I don't think so I
think everyone's asleep that's possible
well you give them a call if you want or
it's it's you got to walk it I can walk
it all right how far you just in Town up
College Hill I'm over on the south side
of
campus in a dorm yeah all
right um where are we right now like oh
I'll show you on a map you are downtown
right ring
finger you are downtown right
now you familiar with the area a
little
just Google Maps it yeah there you go
your phone's still have power where is
your phone by the
way I don't think I have it I didn't see
it we usually take all the stuff off you
can put in the box I don't see a phone
oh yeah shoot huh right ring finger
let's focus here for now we'll talk
about phones in a minute probably lost
it last night huh I think so I think I
had it when I was picked up all right
that's got to be a good one come
on
what all right let's try
that yeah little finger
do you by chance have any water mhm I
do let's get you cup after this finger
all
right step over
here oh we don't want that at all have
you had a drink at all this
evening take back in your cell you got a
sink go fill that up for
you
it just turn
off yeah how'd you turn it
on yeah let's we'll let it go and it
should turn off all right
yeah
back at it he just put that down over
here left thumb the left hand is always
tricky let's see how it goes thumb
Thum index
pointer
middle this is not going to
work
how long you been at WSU um this is my
first semester
oh how's it been for you pretty good
good let's try the other direction I'm
going to rotate this way starting to
hate my major though oh what do you got
K oo gosh yeah those are my worst
classes back in the day left
little yeah chemistry and they're not
gentle when you're new that stuff comes
at you fast it's not like the other
classes it's very abstract yeah and
ain't going to
go you know what we going to do we'll
try one
more okay this is weird stuff can you
put out there you
go so this is kind of like lotion let's
see how that
works try
that
I'm I take it all
right wipe some of that
off oh that's a good
one
no way man we're good all right so you
have a seat over in that brown chair
there I'll have you sign a few things
and we'll be out of
here
[Applause]
for
so you didn't did they take anything
from you when you get out here like
nothing okay yes what did they take from
you chapstick took a ChapStick from you
and had little cards on and my hat I
think really all right well I don't have
anything here I'll ask real quick but I
don't have nothing regarding that they
would have taken it from you you would
ass signed a paper saying we took it and
you would put it in a box I'm not seeing
nothing in a box okay so first off my
hat's down there oh here's a box that is
not a hat you go that's not a hat you
miss okay and you got a phone there you
go so we're going to sign
right I have ver far all the above prod
has been returned to me so look through
your stuff make sure you got everything
and then we're going to sign right
here all
right Uno cards there they
are that's all right you take all your
stuff I'm keeping the Box you get the
hat and all the stuff there
signature
okay let see sign
that that's for me that's for me sign
here write make a note for
you sign where that blue line is and
also another one over
here Sign Here sign here